[Music]
in the future movies will consist of
nothing but logos and we will be begging
for a sequel you're out those are for
bones
largely yeah it's kind of ridiculous
that this race of people who are so
paranoid about the Bonin's that they
jump to conclusions this quickly even
bothered to allow Kirk into their
council with a gift from them also these
opening scenes are usually fan fantastic
can we not see a whole movie that led to
the scene just once even as a webseries
this angry alien attacking Kirk but
turning out to be super tidy yeah that's
one of the biggest labs in all of 2016
cinema and I'm taking off two sins for
it because did you see that that's
hilarious did you manage to broker a
treaty with the 10x II uh let's just say
it came up short geez you're not only
stealing the James Bond action scene
openers you're also stealing his puns
when you look mark that balls fuck it
definitely won't be important later this
is hilarious but did they basically just
kidnap these guys and fly away without
beaming them back down as for me things
have started to feel a little episodic
our our TV show Carhartt I found this in
Chekhov's Locker
okay so again that's funny but what the
hell's bones doing rummaging through
people's lockers and to check off leave
it unlocked or his bones a master lock
picker I always assumed it'd be a vodka
vodka guy that's Russia sparingly the
Federation decided to build Elysium on
this planet this is a public transporter
which would seem to negate the need for
the Train we saw just a few seconds ago
but what do I know
now these people still together do I
care about it actually I forwarded to
the part where we find out that they
broke it up for some reason how do I
know they broke up if i forward it
through it you might ask well that's a
very interesting story that skip I don't
think any of us care that sue Lee was
gay but the problem is assuming that
because George Takei is gay and
therefore the character he made
Popular's gay is kind of silly and the
antithesis of acting the Vulcans who met
Spock right after he got off the ship
during a bright sunny day decided to
conduct their meeting at night in a
private courtyard next to a giant
Terminator hand current modern Star Trek
series actually handles real-life
Leonard Nimoy's death with restraint and
grace
another set off Greg Grunberg is like JJ
Abrams Bruce Campbell isn't the
enterprise does have the best
navigational system in the fleet of
course it does the only ship here with
more advanced technology is still under
construction of course it is and the
enterprise is back to work trading on
the shore leave never lasts as long as
it's supposed to movie trope that
extends beyond Star Trek into all the
film haha be on Star Trek you can see
did their own complete accident cuz it's
hilarious the enterprise is something no
other ship in the fleet has you
inspiring definitely need to give your
crew some confidence going into a
difficult mission but if I'm some sort
of peon on the ship I'm wondering what
makes us so special didn't we all go to
the same school anyway I guess I'll take
it
q Frank missile loader on the USS
derivative its ultimate my ship is
stranded here as the movie will go on to
prove the enterprise and Starfleet as
well is really stupid for trusting the
eyewitness account of one individual no
life-forms on the surface because
Starfleet sensors are worthless what is
this who cares why are you waiting so
long to put the shields up or flying
away I know Kirk thinks he can take on
everything in the universe with the
enterprise but what makes him think it's
gonna be successful this time I mean at
this point I guess he knows that he's in
the movie and nothing kill him even
though within five minutes crow will
have the artifact he needs these ships
will somehow only break the enterprise
into large survivable sections instead
of millions of pieces which is what I do
if I were a swarm of bee ships and they
took out the dish shields are inoperable
inoperable as in not suitable to be
operated on it's an honest enough
mistake but you clearly met inoperative
and whoever wrote the script or edited
this movie thinks the two words are
interchangeable captain there's a chance
I can redo the energy reserves from the
warp core to the impulse engines Scotty
can liar okay these ships pierce the
hole to get here the enterprise has lost
its shields meaning this hallway should
have the environment of space right now
and all these redshirt assholes are
already dead I mean right what am I
missing
well stinks can't possibly have made an
airtight seal ah authorize it apparently
the reason for these guys attacking the
ship was to steal the artifact from the
beginning of the movie so now that they
have it why do they give a shit about
Spock yeah Don did present impulse great
work mr. Scott maximum input yes it's
literally life or death right now
let's take time to pay the chief
engineer a compliment before giving a
potentially life-saving order Jesus oh
no the enterprise is dead again I wonder
if they'll repair to find a way to bring
it back somehow when was us I mean
exactly it was moved by the anymore
crawl manages to find Kirk who I guess
teleported to this very spot on the ship
and started running so he could be
spotted ahora Lux out with an alien who
doesn't shoot her immediately like all
the other aliens have done these
assholes survive this movie steals the
empty box from every movie ever but
let's say it's sneakers people's engines
drawing power from auxiliary generators
man the lure preserves the auxiliary
generators these impulse engines can
draw power from anything but my biggest
gripe is that any of the ship lasted
long enough for him to even say this
this ship has been
whipping over like a quarter before a
football game for ten minutes now but
for the shot while it's still flipping
mind you Kirk is able to stand perfectly
still on the bridge and solemnly
contemplate his failures of course Kirk
gets a first-hand view of his ships
final demolition because it wouldn't be
poetic if he didn't what look what you
did Kirk you big dumb ass movie probably
didn't mean it but I'm getting a serious
Star Trek generations behind here and
that's not a good thing Star Trek film
goes on fast and furious on our asses
wait a second luckily Kirk landed in
about exactly the same area where the
woman who betrayed him land it
horizontal an alien planet thank God
Starfleet has female officers wear
skirts am i right
also while I'm at it thank God aka the
screenwriter this alien planet has
breathable air for humans no fish is
whoa this guy's koba's speech patterns
are distracting no seriously apes follow
come on now now replay his life fish is
I mean you see the bottom it he will
come for us on so your plan is to
destroy the enterprise killing dozens
then capture the survivors and wait for
the captain to come rescue them do I
have that right I've seen this movie so
I know you don't have a Kirk specific
vendetta so isn't this just a chilling
line that ultimately means nothing cuz I
think it is haha Spock
how are you not dead but it'll cut the
hole doctor I fail to see how excrement
of any kind bears relevance on a current
situation are you telling me Spock has
been on this ship for years and he's
never once heard someone use bulgar
horse and doesn't know what it means
that's bullsh
Welsh this is cool I'd remove the sin
but I just don't see how this works at
all I mean Holograms are actually
physically fighting these guys if they
were simply hologram distractions that's
one thing but these are actually making
physical contact you would never need an
army if this is possible is that English
I learn it from my house plus it saves
us the burden of hearing that translator
thing again and it's convenient for the
story so and you a Montgomery Scott I
Scotty
calm now I'm gone the Scottish gala is
exactly the breath of fresh air this
Star Trek series needed and I'm taking
us in off for her awesomeness I'd add a
prize come in he thinks this could
possibly work Spock is literally the
only Enterprise crew member to survive
this crash landing but with major
medical issues everyone else either died
or is just peachy only Spock has an
injury weird the console is infected
look out
as its needs we got about 15 minutes
until the next guard rotation MA and
you're able to figure out their guard
schedule with the sample size of a
couple of hours maybe and 15 minutes I
mean the most of these assholes have to
guard and can't they keep one guy
standing outside to keep watch and how
do they know no one's doing that and I
guess even if they had one guard keeping
watch they'd use the old someone's
having a heart attack in here routine to
escape but damn he's access to your time
database Carl is using the Magellan
probe that cut through the nebula and
hack into Starfleet one of the biggest
problems Starfleet was having was
cutting through the nebula with these
very same probes but my question is
there wasn't one person who could figure
out how to make these things work before
they sent the enterprise blindly into
the nebula here crawls man catch these
enterprise crew members up to no good
but does he have him killed of course
not
he's a villain with a conscience that
kicks in only after he's destroyed a
ship and killed 50 percent of its crew
in the process then he becomes a big
softy Kirk shoots his phaser into the
combustion chamber and that ignites the
fuel so the ship can fly do I have that
right this girl lied to Kirk and but man
she did it for good reasons yep I'm
still apparently supposed to be glad
she's dying
well there goes the enterprise again
luckily many years ago crawl flew a
similar ship here that crash-landed that
they'll be able to use to get back
jumping away from an explosion just as
it goes off cliche this journey I'm this
lieutenant this works kept strictly
enough I brought you to this very spot
to talk to you so I can show off my
human power sucker 5000 constructed from
corrugated hoses and matrix II doodads
glad you gave me that strength in unity
line because it makes this demonstration
all the more dramatic and this planet is
really foggy I think I see the misty
mountain a Messer Spock has died I want
to live as he did one day I hope someone
will send me to a planet with a Ruby
cave so I can see my homeworld destroyed
and another Spock from another dimension
just happens to stumble on me when it
happens
that music of course not it's rap
someone set off one of my trucks and
it's Kirk and check off of course this
is a planet right like a whole planet
because if so what are the odds
don't heart them because they take you
to jail it decides the best way to
handle this is by not telling anybody
what she's doing
thereby causing more harm than necessary
captured by a giant green space hand
Green Lantern she's rigged up gamings
refractors so Klingon or Romulan
cloaking technology
she just invented that or he's saying
image refractors are a thing that exists
in the Federation just never implemented
this tech to have their own cloaking
ships like some sort of holographic
camouflage eisah looks glitches though
and something crawl should have already
discovered or is the flashing just for
the viewers so they remember there's a
ship under there
of course these crawl soldiers can
instantly track and locate a radio
signal but a transporter signal will
baffle them completely hologram
confusing this of death haircloth
storage also this girl defies orders
opens her face hugger head and Gibbs
crawl the very thing kirk want to hide
from crawl and which Sulu was ready to
die to protect stupid face hugger head
girl also good thing she didn't get lost
or exploded during the enterprise attack
huh good see it's not your strength joke
this I could have sworn MC Hammer
declared that sweetness was humanity's
weakness but whatever I guess scroll has
just about as much street cred as hammer
does these days so Who am I to say this
MacGuffin is a lot like the first movies
MacGuffin remember the red matter it's a
scary weapon the details of which don't
matter just so long as our heroes
thwarted in time apparently if you use
outdated medical equipment on someone
who's been bleeding internally they can
walk around as if it never happened
within minutes but it's unique signature
makes it very easy to identify you get
your girlfriend a tracking device that
was not my intention
one of the best laughs I've had in a
long time once at all I am detecting in
wary trace amount the what Gaea in a
minute check off is gonna claim they
can't transport the crew out of the area
because of some geological interference
but this computer can detect a
radioactive Vulcan rock that his
girlfriend is luckily wearing around her
neck through that interference if you
choose to do this you're on your own the
alien who is obviously going to help
them has to pitch up it first so the
audience thinks she's not gonna help
them because this movie is basically a
coloring book loved the motorcycle
diversion plan but this shot suggests
the motorcycle was travelling at full
speed before the transporter even
started working which is goddamn
ridiculous just be met static standing
still
we don't have a problem splitted into
two and dejected the hearts into space
hoping it would be lost forever
why do assholes who want something
dangerous gone always do something that
totally asurs it will be found somehow
someway this is the parallax situation
only with less digging crawl puts a
thing into a whatever and some stuff
happens leading to seals death ancient
stolen weapon is basically the nanobots
from Michael Crichton's prey remember
earlier in the movie when you were
counting on Kirk showing up why do you
look so surprised right now given you
already have the all-powerful deadly
weapon why were you ever counting on
Kirk showing up one of these is the
actual Kirk meaning the captain has put
himself in danger once again I mean cool
distraction bro it's like Russian
roulette with Holograms look even if
you're projecting doubles of yourself
somehow they're not all turning in
different directions are they wouldn't
they all mirror the movements of elf
good I'm going for more wine let's hope
this doesn't get messy
energize somehow reconfiguring an
outdated ship that barely has any power
to beam 20 people at a time doesn't get
messy I have the element of surprise on
the person killing all my guards I shall
use my mighty feet and throwing ability
instead of weapons to take her down oh
look the guy that killed her family has
found her in his attacking her
this is poetic for sure but if I'm Manus
I'd be attacking Kirk not Jalen but I
guess poetry outweighs common sense here
the way it does in a Jane Austen
adaptation Oh Deus Ex ahora she's a
great fighter with a vendetta but this
dude is still gonna basically own her
because the movie wants you to feel
tension on winsomeness board disk Kim oh
god damn it so I guess this movie has
time for some villainous taunting will
that make his death more satisfying
probably not Jayla is an easy grabbing
distance but this asshole allows her to
get on top of this thing anyway
here's a whole world of both and this is
where getting a fast and furious
director comes in I guess
besides how did that transporter not
already beam Kirk before he got there
anyway that's there yeah yeah
this isn't Kirk being funny and
exhausted this is Chris Pine talking to
the director about this stunt heavy
movie these old vessels they were built
in space they were never supposed to
take off from atmosphere
shut up Scotty just make the impossible
happen that's what you're here for ship
plane is clearly going to crash guy
except it's not and this is just a silly
fake out scene cliche thank god this 100
year old Starfleet vehicle was built to
withstand multiple impacts with
mountains am i right this face Sulu had
no idea that would work and he
simultaneously impressed and mystified
and that is worthless in off Scotty can
you beam me on in one of those swarm
ships have you gone completely mad this
should be pretty much impossible but
Scott is going to beam two people onto
one of these bee ships thousands of
swarming bee ships all going in
different patterns and he's gonna get
the precise coordinates to do just that
Spock you're still hurt is he good thing
the ejection panels for the ship bar
this far away from the actual pilots
chair kind of makes you wonder what
these pilots would do if they were in a
ship that was on fire that's a good
choice it was indeed but the odds of her
picking this one song Kirk has a
previous association with her so
astronomical I'm gonna sin it anyway
that's a dam I just love that this is
the way they're gonna kill these things
it's inventive and smart and I've gotta
hand it to them for this scene we're
moving us in faster doc can we risk
being consumed by their tragic toriel
decay um can't Scotty just beam them out
of this thing if you say no to this
remember Scotty has done about 50
impossible things in this movie already
including beaming them onto the ship and
sure it becomes useful later that
they're in this ship but they didn't
know that was going to happen so now in
all this creamy chocolatey firey
goodness crawl manages to escape the
damage that is inflicted on all the
ships around him and continue this movie
for another 20 minutes the USS franklin
and its occupants survived this space
cops intercepting all three ships is an
impossibility you mean you can't keep
playing sabotage and destroy the last
three ships he'll Yorktown has the
frequency now what's preventing this
amazing attack from working again
did Carl turn on his anti sabotaging
shields yes this does feel like a happy
climax but this movie still has 30
minutes left if you can believe that
just like in the darkness this modern
Star Trek movie refuses to end at the
obvious point instead subjecting us to
yet more unbelievable shenanigans the
horror rewound this thing about a
hundred and seventy four times but
neglected to let it play two seconds
after so that she Kirk and we could see
Idris Elba's face which is the important
thing I don't know how
while we're all being amazed that an old
Starfleet captain slash assumed dead
hero turned into a monster
basically Colonel Kurtz from Apocalypse
Now this is a bit troublesome because
remember Jayla found the USS franklin
and put refractors on the ship to keep
it hidden
but wouldn't crawl if knowing where the
ship was since he crash-landed there
have some soft knowledge a that belong
huh yeah if you have enough living
people to suck out their power but you
just said you only have three of your
crew left and the indigenous species
left the planet and left behind only
drones so why did you not die long ago
with no species fuel to power the
technology and how do you turn these
drones which were made for mining into
an elite swarming fighting force in
space this reveal actually brings up way
more questions under the iteration do
not care about us um you got lost though
behind a crippling nebula is it possible
in your view that the Federation simply
has no idea where you wit as he wants to
find some more don't fuck maximum damage
he needs a distribution system have to
circulate air here right jeez I mean we
came up with that in like two seconds
also know the corkscrew man-made
moon-sized city of Yorktown does not
require air I mean duh that's the only
way this planet sighs Space Station only
has one way to access its airflow only
one I mean if you ever need to repair
this for any reason right
Kirk is easily distracted giving the
dangerous crawl the upper hand Wow this
super weapon doesn't even need to be
plugged into anything huh who would have
thunk it this weapon that's four of them
there are four hatches for this air
distributor system that is never
supposed to be open in the first place
why are there four hatches why are there
four hatches must be some way of getting
interest elbow back into the action of
guessing if the hatch is open when the
processor cycles in units you're gonna
get sucked into space provided of course
that you don't hang on to the easily
hang on able hatch frames when it
happens which is exactly what he's gonna
do dammit Jim you won't make it out in
time yes he will they killed and revived
him last movie so he's untouchable now
do you even Mubi bones
Spock enough this guy is getting hoisted
by his own petard this swarming evil
swarming stuff destroys everything
except well-known Star Trek symbols huh
Spock had a publicity photo from one of
the Star Trek movies in his possession
not the adventure he just went through
with Kurt but instead it's the picture
of the other timelines Enterprise crew
that ultimately changes Spock's mind
about quitting Starfleet that's the
future impacting the past paradox
hey Kaiser I'll remind everyone that
this is a proud race of people that have
suddenly become Starfleet pets that's
racist at some point Starfleet has got
to be all like that's it
we are not building any more enterprises
you keep clean them all up I got to
admit the sped up enterprise
construction footage is kind of awesome
and is definitely new and unique so what
the hell I'll take another sin off
since this hippie alpha 5 excuse me
don't wait for the translation answer me
now the microbots are controlled with
this neural transmitter
[Music]
nothing Yuri must conquer the face not
the bears the fact is he got every mob
in town Eastside Westside ready to pull
together but we take this downtown and
we get in a money game that is ain't
going to jail we are now entering the
Mutara nebula I promise I won't hurt you
now come here no all right you want
something to eat